all eyes of the international community
are on the canadian government right now
they recently invoked emergency powers
to go after the trucker conflict those
people protesting the government
mandated vaccines and masks but
ultimately what people are worried about
is not the mandates or the protest what
they're worried about is this huge
authoritarian overreach by the canadian
government to start to actually censor
and use economic and financial sanctions
against your own citizens is usually
something that's reserved for your
enemies at war the united states is
currently trying to sanction russia
china is actually sanctioning u.s
companies but in canada they're not
sanctioning other countries they're
sanctioning their own citizens this is
absurd but they're not done yet what we
saw is that the government in canada is
now moving to make these expanded
surveillance powers over financial
transactions permanent we've got a quote
here from the canadian finance minister
which she says we reviewed very very
carefully the tools at the disposal the
federal government and we used all the
tools that we had prior to the
invocation of the emergencies act and we
determined that we needed some
additional tools now some of those tools
will be putting forward measures to put
those tools permanently in place the
authorities of fintrac i believe do need
to be expanded to cover crowdsourcing
platforms and their payment providers
this is insane what we are watching is
the temporary measures that were used
during the invocation of the emergencies
act are now going to be made permanent
the government is going to expand their
surveillance capabilities they are going
to push further and further into
financial censorship they believe the
best way to quell dissent against their
government policies is to treat their
citizens like terrorists or adversaries
of war to use economic sanctions but
that's not it the people of canada are
starting to only begin to feel the pain
of their government apparently the
police are now going after business
owners that have remained open
during the protest justin trudeau said
that he'd respect the charter of rights
while invoking the emergencies act but
the destruction of the fabric of the
canadian society is happening right
before canadians eyes it comes from viva
frey and so ultimately what we are
watching is that governments in times of
chaos distress uncertainty and fear
begin to expand their powers but there's
nothing more permanent than a temporary
government measure and ultimately what
we have to do as technologists and as
global citizens so we have to build open
source technology to be able to resist
the overreaches of government we already
saw as dennis porter pointed out that
everyone understood the bitcoin hardcap
of 21 million after governments and
central banks around the world printed
trillions now those same citizens will
understand why censorship resistant
technologies will matter after canada
moves to make their nation into a
surveillance state most people didn't
think that we would see something like
this in the western democratic liberal
world that's exactly what we're getting
people are waking up and more and more
people are realizing bitcoin isn't just
an investment tool bitcoin is financial
sovereignty and that's about to become a
lot more important in the future hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time